الحوار بدات تحت الهواء مشاهدين في
الاستوديو منرحب بالفنانه انجي وريحان
والمخرج يحيى جابر اهلا وسهلا صباح الخير
انا حابه ابلش معكم
انجو حابه ابلش معك ليش مجدره حمراء طبعا
انا يعني عرفت ليه في النهايه لانه هو
احدى شخصياتها واحد شخصيات
المسرحيه المسرحيه كتير بتحب المجدره
الحمراء بس المجدره اصلا مش حمراء مجدرتنا
بالجنوب اللبنانيه للجنوبيه هي بصير لونها
احمر لانه بتنعمل هي بالعدس الصغير الاحمر
اذا بدنا نفوت بالتفصيل ولما بيتقلل بصل
مع ميه العدس بيعطي هذا
فكره انه الموضوع كله
والمنطقه اللي هي بتنتمي واكيد
يعني تسميه مجدره حمراء بالتحديد الى معنى
كثير كبير بالمسرحيه ما فينا نفس السر
حاليا بس موجوده يعني في ثلاث نساء وفي
المجدره بقلب المسرحيه
في العالم العربي هل تجد لها صدى ولا هو
تفرد
اعتقد انه بس تكون
شغوف بالعمل يلي عم تعمله وعارف انه هذا
العمل يعني انت حاطط به من كل الجوانب
وحطيت في كل نقاطك القوه فيك تتفرد باي
شيء بدك تعمله بس يكون في صدق وفي حب
فبيوصل وبفتكر هلا صار في صرنا بعصر كل
العالم عم تجرب تتميز والارجح او الافضل
انه نتميز بطريقه فنيه وثقافيه متميزه
فعشان هيك حسينا مع الاستاذ يحيى جابر
يعني
بس هو اللي
دل على سنتين
دراما وانا كنت ما كتير
مستعده لهذا الشيء وهلا كمان مثل ما
بشكروا عاده بشكر هيدي الفرصه يلي سمحتلي
عملنا اسمي جوليا قبل مسرحيه بال 2016 وما
زلنا عاملين هذا الثنائي لغايه الان اها
طيب استاذ يحيى
المسرح عده عناصر دائما المخرج هو من يمسك
بخيوطها صح مونو دراما ممثل او ممثله
واحده تقوم بكل الشخصيات وتجسد يعني
الكثير ان لم يكن كل عناصر المسرحيه من
الصعب يعني هي طريقه اخراج اصعب من لما
يكون في عندك شخصيات متعدده في المسرحيه
كيف تعملت معها
فعلا اول شيء المسرح بدا هو اساسا
الاول ومن ثم انتقل مع الجوقه وانتقل الى
بعدين مجموعه ماسكينه على الخشمي بالنسبه
للمولودرام
كحفل التعذيب فيها
والعمل
التاليف والاخراج سوا طيب يعني مش لازم
تكون محكمه جدا لانه ما فيش غير شخص واحد
يؤدي
حقل تجارب حقيقي
استسلمت لارواحها
وبلاشت اعجن اخبز يعني مي
وبلش تطلع ارواح منها سبكت
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيه والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات